the MCU is back in Action as the strikes
are now over both the writer strike and
the actor strike are both officially
done and hopefully now the delays are
over we've had a lot of delays but now
it seems like we have a firm locked in
schedule but a lot of people have been
asking what does the new schedule look
like what is the order what are all of
the release dates and when can we expect
to see all of these movies and shows and
I'll admit it has been a little bit
confusing with all of the delays and all
of the changes going on right now
because of the strikes so in this video
we'll go over every single MCU project
that is coming up with their release
dates will also throw in the Sony
Spider-Man universe projects in there as
well because without those projects
unfortunately Marvel Studios is only
going to be releasing one movie in 2024
but with the Sony movies we'll actually
get four movies yes Sony is releasing
three Marvel spiderverse movies in 2024
for so let's go over the order and the
release dates for every upcoming Marvel
project and if you're new be sure to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest Marvel
news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you are automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month so the
next Marvel project that we're going to
be getting is what if season 2 this has
been announced to be coming out on
December 22nd of 2023 and they are going
to be releasing one episode every day
starting on the 22nd so episode 1 comes
out December 22nd episode 2 comes out
December 23rd episode 3 December 24th
and so on and so forth there will be
Nine episodes so there will be nine
straight days of what if season 2
including a Christmas episode with happy
just in time for the holidays
interesting way that Marvel Studios is
doing it but the next project after that
is the echo series coming on January
10th of 2024 and Marvel has decided to
release all of the episodes at once for
Ekko so clearly with their Disney plus
content Marvel is switching it up trying
a few different things seeing what works
for them and I got to say I wasn't that
excited for Echo I definitely was going
to watch it but after watching the
trailer it actually looks fantastic it
gives off Netflix Daredevil Vibes which
makes sense because Kingpin is one of
the main characters Daredevil himself is
going to make a cameo appearance and the
series and aloa Cox looks like she did
phenomenal work on the series and it's
the first MCU project to be given the
rating of mature so those who like the
Daredevil series on Netflix this is
probably going to be right up your alley
then the next Marvel project not
necessarily MCU project but Marvel
project coming up after the echo series
is madam web this is coming out February
14th of 2024 and it's actually supposed
to be a pretty important movie for the
spiderverse and the comics mam web has
the ability to travel throughout the
Multiverse and since we believe Sony is
leading up to a huge big Grand Avengers
in-game level event with their
spiderverse this is kind of the first
step to making all of this come together
so hopefully it's decent and sets up the
future then we have our only Marvel
Studios movie for 2024 and that is
Deadpool 3 coming out July 26th and of
course this is a massive film for the
MCU we know Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is
going to be returning along with some
other Fox X-Men characters some of the
ogs and this is reportedly the project
that is going to start really dealing
with incursions and the Multiverse
falling apart and a big multiversal hero
team being put together the Multiverse
Avengers team so definitely mark your
calendars for Deadpool 3 then we have
another Sony film Craven the Hunter
coming out August 30th of 2024 and this
is supposedly going to have a tiny
Spider-man connection as well again Sony
is really trying to to piece together
their spider-verse so we're going to
hear and see hints of Spider-Man in all
of these projects then we have one that
a lot of Marvel fans are really excited
for Agatha coven of chaos the series
coming to Disney Plus on September 19th
of 2024 and of course this is an MCU
project AG of the heartness returns she
is out of the spell that she was put
under from the Scarlet Witch in W
division there will be a lot of other
witches in this show plus Aubrey Plaza
is going to be playing a character that
is supposed to be insanely powerful so
keep an eye out for this one then we
have the very long awaited Venom 3 from
Sony this is Tom Hardy's last Venom film
and he has teased for a while that he
really wants a Venom versus Spider-Man
film plus not to mention some insiders
have recently said that we are going to
see Spider-Man and Venom face off
against each other sooner than we think
so perhaps a Spider-Man I say a
Spider-Man could be in this film Venom 3
I say a Spider-Man because it could be
Tom Hollands it could be Andrew
Garfield's we're not sure at this point
but I would guess that they would
probably have Tom Holland Spider-Man in
there since for the Venom 3 post credit
and the Spider-Man no way home post
credit they both teased the Venom
symbiote and Venom crossed over into the
MCU but then went back but now Venom
knows who Spider-Man is so it seems like
this is all going to come to fruition in
venom 3 fingers crossed then at some
point in time in 2024 we don't have an
official release date yet we are getting
X-Men 997 The Animated Series which I am
just super stoked for if you watch the
Animated Series as a kid or whenever you
could have watched it just recently
hopefully you are really excited for
this one as well then moving into 2025
the first movie of the year is going to
be Captain America Brave New World this
was recently delayed unfortunately
moving from 2024 to 2025 but the reason
they supposedly delayed the movie
according to Insider Daniel rpk is so
they could refilm and shoot better fight
scenes evidently they were comparing the
fight scenes in Brave New World to the
old Captain America films and they
weren't as good so to make sure that
this movie is good they are re-shooting
them which I am all for plus of course
we should be getting Red Hulk in this
movie so I am super pumped for that and
I know a lot of other people are as well
and 2025 really is a packed year for
Marvel Studios because everything got
delayed there's a lot happening in 2025
because after Captain America 4 comes
the Fantastic 4 currently set for the
release date of May 2nd 20 25 and this
movie is supposed to be pretty epic we
should get the cast announcement
relatively soon within the month and
we've done a lot of videos on the
Fantastic 4 so if you really want to
know what's going on you can check out
our other videos but the villain is
supposed to be galatis the Silver Surfer
is supposed to appear and Reed Richards
and Sue Storm's kids Valeria Richards
and Franklin Richards are supposedly
going to appear as well and I think all
MCU fans are super excited for this one
then another movie from Marvel in 2025
we have the Thunderbolts coming out July
2th 5th 2025 this one's going to be
really interesting because century is
going to debut in this film plus we have
a lot of characters that we've come to
know and love over time in the MCU this
is reportedly going to be kind of like
the suicide squad however what's really
going to happen is a team is put
together and they don't really know that
they're a Suicide Squad so they figure
it out and then they kind of rebel
against whoever put the team together
we'll have to wait and see on that one
but we do know the Thunderbolts are
going to have to go up against the
century so we're really excited for this
one then coming November 7th of 2025 we
have blade this movie has been through
so many rewrites at this point in time
I'm just glad that Mersa Ali is still on
board I'm glad that they still have a
release date for it even though it's
been pushed back and I really hope that
they can nail this script and this movie
ends up being good because so far I
think it's had four rewrites which is
not good but at least they are
acknowledging that the scripts are bad
and are willing to rewrite them and push
the movie back to have a good good movie
so let's hope it turns out well cuz I'm
really excited for the supernatural side
of the MCU then going into
2026 on May 1st we have Avengers King
Dynasty the first Avengers film since
Avengers endgame so hopefully they go
all out with this one we assume the
Avengers go up against Kang possibly the
Kang Trio and then they lose and that
brings us into Avengers Secret Wars
where they tried to avenge the
Multiverse again we assume they lose an
Avengers King Dynasty in the Multiverse
kind of starts to collapse and that'll
be the premise of Avengers Secret Wars
defeating the Council of kings and then
most likely trying to restore the
Multiverse Avengers Secret Wars right
now listed on marvel.com is set for May
7th of 2027 let's hope that does not get
delayed there have been some insiders
who have stated they would be shocked if
it came out before 2028 but let's hope
they're wrong on that one and it sticks
to this release date now these are all
the the projects that we have confirmed
release dates for even if it's just a
confirmed year we still have some sort
of a confirmed release date for every
project we just mentioned there are
other projects of course that are coming
at some point in time we just don't know
when like the Iron Heart series we
believe it's coming out sometime in 2024
however that's not confirmed also armor
Wars we know that armor Wars is now
going to be a movie and not a show but
this isn't even listed on Marvel Studios
website it is there you can find it if
you search for but when you go to all
Marvel movies it is not listed and when
you do find it by searching it does not
give a release date so if we hear
anything about armor Wars or any other
Marvel project that does not have a
confirmed release date yet we'll of
course be sure to do an update video
informing you so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos please don't forget to like the
video and hit that notification Bell and
let us know what project you are most
excited for in the comments down below
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
if you'd like and as always thank you
all so much for watching W wolf